[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue dans ce set
8 sport sur tv 78 voici à le sommaire de
ce à magazine couvre-feu le sport et
bin-houin va être fortement impacté par
cette mesures prises face à la crise
sanitaire
des bâches ont déjà été annulées dans
les yvelines et les clubs vont devoir
s'adapter pour les entraînements coup de
projecteur dans ce magazine football ont
joué ce week-end le 5e tour de la coupe
de france conflent réussi à s'imposer ce
dimanche à domicile contre aulnésienne
aux tirs au but
le club est le dernier représentant yves
binois reportage à suivre golf un stade
de haute performance a été inaugurée
mercredi dernier au golf national de
saint quentin en yvelines
cet équipement permettra aux golfeurs
français de travailler tous les types de
groupes focus dans ce un magazine
l'actualité sportive c'est maintenant
sur tv 78
[Musique]
je vous le disais dans les titres se
couvre feu imposé de 21h à 6h dans la
région ile de france face à la crise
faillite a également des conséquences
sur le monde sportif local dcl habits
noirs vont devoir se réorganiser pour
les entraînements pendant au moins
quatre semaines et certains matchs
seront à tanus les ou reprogrammées les
détails et réactions
le monde du sport et vie noailles
bousculé par le couvre-feu annoncé ce
mercredi soir par emmanuel macron
certains matchs de basketball au de
handball programmé en soirée sont d'ores
et déjà annulés dans le département au
club de football de poissy ne devrait
pas y avoir de conséquences sur les
matches à domicile de l'équipe senior
les rencontres de nationale 2 son
programme est généralement en fin de
journée mais ce sont les rencontres à
l'extérieur en bretagne qui interroge
les dirigeants le match se déroule à 18
heures donc à 20h45 ce qu'il faut une
heure de battement nous partons avec nos
équipes devront nous restait
effectivement sur la bretagne et les
frais nécessaires et supplémentaires
dont ce sera difficile à supporter
compte tenu de notre budget restés sur
place 20 personnes sur un hôtel
effectivement ce n'est pas envisageable
pour nous néanmoins si nous rentrons
j'espère vraiment nous aurons des
dérogations au delà des matches ce
couvre feu va entraîner une
réorganisation des horaires
d'entraînement le soir pour l'ensemble
des clubs
ivy noah c'est le cas au rugby-club de
versailles les conséquences sont surtout
organisationnel avec l'avancée de tous
les deux tout les horaires
d'entraînement notamment pour les
seniors et les juniors qui s'entraînait
jusqu'à 21h30 au 20h30
évidemment avant c'est désormais à 19
heures pour terminer à 20h15 20h30 grand
maximum et pour que tout le monde soit
rentrer chez soi a tenté
la vie autour des rencontres va
également être perturbé les après matchs
si renommé dans le monde du rugby vont
être impactés par les nouvelles mesures
annoncées
3e mi-temps sont remplacés par des
distributions sans rassemblement de
manière à éviter que le virus ne se
propage
après des matchs et dans des conditions
dans des caissons festive qui sont du
coup à revoir mais encore une fois tant
qu'on peut jouer au rugby on fait avec
il faudra faire avec pendant au minimum
quatre semaines pour le sport et binoy
vous l'avez vu dans leurs reportages
précédents cette situation inquiète
inquiète et perturbe le monde sportif
yves binois ce week-end certains matches
ont déjà été annulé et reprogrammé
c'était le cas pour le match de
nationale 2 féminine de
montigny-le-bretonneux ou de l'équipe
masculine de plaisir en nationale 3 les
matchs de basket de trappes encore du
chesnay versailles ont eux aussi été
annulés
le cv 78 devait jouer contre laïque et
montivilliers et le match a été déplacé
au 28 novembre pour nous parler de cette
situation nous recevons sur ce plateau à
bamba cei et mehdi atallah deux joueurs
de l'équipe
bonsoir messieurs bonsoir mais alors
comment avez-vous appris l'annulation de
ce match bamba c'est l'annulation l'a
appris la veille
je crois et parce qu'on attendait
un message pour nous dire qu'on allait
jouer mais bon après le cauchemar
message contre tous les matches sont
annulés et
on était un peu déçu quand également dit
s'y attendait un petit peu
lors du dernier entraînement on en avait
parlé le jeudi on attendait le message
le vendredi pour savoir si on partait en
déplacement ou pas parce que avec la
réservation du carré et toute la
logistique du club et on a reçu un
message vendredi dans la matinée pour
savoir qui nous disaient que le match
n'allait pas avoir lieu et qui seraient
déplacées au au 28 ans 28 novembre vous
avez plus un petit peu discuté avec les
autres joueurs des autres équipes
présentes dans votre poule non non on
n'a pas discuté franchement et mais
c'est quoi le sentiment général c'est
que tout le monde est déçu et comme vu
qu'on était tout le monde était bien
parti pour faire
bonne saison et que la cette coupure
nous c'est un peu gênant quoi alors vous
pensez que ça peut fausser le
championnat
peut-être 10 euros 'pour moi moi je
pense que oui particulièrement dans une
poule il ya des trappes a joué un match
de plus que nous nous on a joué je crois
trois matches de plus que rouen qui a
joué qu'un seul match ou deux matches de
plus donc forcément si ça vient à
s'arrêter à un moment donné on aura on
n'aura pas tous toutes les équipes n'ont
pas joué le même nombre de matches donc
je pense que ça peut fausser le jeu
résultats à partir du moment où on n'a
pas tous joué le monde le même nombre de
matches non mais ça y est vous êtes
d'accord
oui je suis d'accord avec lui et surtout
que en province il s'entraîne et vu que
nous on peut plus s'entraîner donc lui
sa fausse tout justement comment ça se
gère au niveau des entraînements parce
que je le rappelle vous ne pouvez plus
vous entraînez maintenant oui on peut
plus s'entraîner donc le coach est en
train de voir des solutions
faire des courses des cordes et aller
s'entraîner à l'extérieur faire beaucoup
de courses et donc après c'est pas ça
qui va nous remettre dedans dans le coup
mais bon on espère qu'on peut d'ici là
il y aura des changements
en basket il faut s'entraîner au tir par
exemple il n'ya pas que la condition
physique
c'est ça le club dans en train de voir
le club avec le coach est en train de
voir pour qu'on puisse entraîner soit
avancé les entraînements mais il faut
voir si tout le monde est disponible ou
bien aller sur des terrains extérieurs
courir mais bon comme on fait enfin
sports collectifs ont fait pareil on
fait pas de l'athlétisme
donc même si on court tous ensemble ça
nous change de sport quoi limite ce sera
plus on pourra plus travailler le basket
quoi et vous n'êtes pas les seuls
concernés ans les filles en nationale 2
sons sont également vu leur match
déplacé également c'est un match contre
contre douvres finalement c'est tout un
club qui est impactée ya peu près 1000
est licencié au chesnay versailles plus
de mille licenciés et
et beaucoup d'équipés qui vont plus
s'entraîner pour six semaines je crois
4,7 à quatre à six semaines
est ce assez ces problématiques
justement là pour vous d'en bas cei qui
avait bien commencé la saison
vous n'êtes plus proche de la fin que du
début on rappelle vous avez 39 ans et
bien sûr merci 42 42 ans donc vous êtes
plus proche de la fin que du début
comment on se maintient en forme
justement voilà ça va être très très
compliqué
je vais essayer de trouver le moyen
d'aller courir de se maintenir mais
c'est pas c'est pas évident c'est pas
évident vous avez marqué 36 points
contre rennes notamment
il faut se maintient en forme surtout à
mon âge est justement ce début de saison
et plus étaient plutôt pas mal
on peut le dire pour pour le chesnay
versailles avec deux victoires une
défaite
est ce que ça peut mettre un petit coup
d'arrêt ce couvre feu
bah oui forcément avec la coupure le
fait qu'on peut on puisse plus entraîné
forcément après on a bien commencé fait
deux victoires une défaite et bas
l'année dernière en trois matches on
était au même bilan on était à deux
victoires une défaite aussi donc
donc oui vaut mieux être à deux
victoires 1 défaite qu'à une victoire
deux défaites on a un bilan positif pour
le moment après ben à savoir quand
est-ce qu'on pourra rejouer jeu je sais
pas vous êtes cinquième du classement
est ce que c'est un classement qui vous
convient pour l'instant oui oui parce
que on n'a fait que trois matches et
qu'elle a un match de retard donc du
tout brosse le nom n'apparaît que je
pense qu'on est bien le top 5 ce sera
l'objectif à la fin de la saison 1 mais
dit ouais c'est l'objectif du club de
toute façon c'était maintenir se
maintenir de fait assez facilement
après si on peut aller chercher plus
haut le club suivra
mais l'objectif c'est clairement de
finir sur les cinq premières places
confirmé dans bas cinq premières places
déception si vous ne rêvez pas finir
dans le top 5 déception en vie parce que
on a une très bonne équipe une équipe
jeune à paris et encore 36 80 voilà et
donc je pense qu'on peut le faire
facilement
je pense merci à tous les deux d'être
passé sur ce plateau bon courage pour la
suite on espère que vous pourrez
reprendre le plus rapidement possible
sur les a parqués on va maintenant
parler football ont joué ce week-end le
5e tour de la coupe de france
confiant a pris sa revanche éliminé
l'année dernière par aulnésienne les
joueurs du département
on a gagné aux tirs au but après un
match à suspense le club continue donc
l'aventuré devient le dernier
représentant yvelinois dans cette
compétition des images de mélanie poké
explosion de joie au stade léon
biancotto l'équipe locale conflent qui
évolue en terrain vient d'éliminer aux
tirs au but aulnésienne une équipe de la
même division
pourtant en rien n'a été simple dans ce
5e tour de coupe de france bousculer les
huit mois sont menés 2-1 pendant une
grosse partie du match par les joueurs
de seine saint denis on a eu des moments
de flottement l'adversaire nous laisser
jouer
donc à un moment donné on sait pas si on
devait accélérer le jeu de par des
passes ou individuellement
donc on a essayé dans un petit peu tous
proposés aux finalement sonné quand même
bien sorti
la fin du match est une histoire des
penaltys les joueurs de conflans
égalisent sur ce fait de jeu
score final 2 partout à la fin du temps
réglementaire les yvelinois remporté
ensuite le match lors d'une stressante
séance de tirs au but 3 c'était dur ça y
est on est passé d'un match avec plein
de rebondissements on a su concrétiser
puis aller au bout et gagner la victoire
gagner le match sur ce chantier
campinchi avec cette victoire conflent
et le dernier représentant des yvelines
encore en course dans cette coupe de
france 2020 2021 est forcément l'équipe
veut aller le plus loin possible au
stade de france ce serait bien non je
plaisante le plus loin possible c'est la
cerise sur le gâteau voilà on continue
on fait notre petit bonhomme de chemin
on travaille on est content d'être
ensemble
le 6e tour de la coupe de france est
programmé à partir du samedi 31 octobre
au stade léon abyan coteaux les joueurs
de football de conflent et d'aulne et
ont tenu à rendre hommage au début du
match à samuel pâtit professeur
d'histoire géographie qui travaille au
collège du bois d'aulne de conflent il
était décapité vendredi dernier dans une
attaque terroriste dans la commune les
joueurs l'ont applaudi pendant une
minute
dans les autres rencontres de cette
coupe de france de football une deuxième
rencontre concernait un club yvelinois
malgré un bon match le club dooya qui
évolue en r2 n'a pas réussi à créer
l'exploit contre bobigny qui évolue en
nationale 2 le club du nord des yvelines
s'est incliné aux tirs au but 3 après un
score de parité d'un but partout après
la prolongation
il reste donc qu'un seul club yvelinois
encore en course on continue à parler à
football dans le championnat de
nationale 3 ont joué un match en retard
le derby entre les mureaux et le fc
mantois s'est soldé par un match nul 1
but partout un résultat qui n'arrange
aucune des deux équipes le fc mantois
est 9e avec une cette victoire depuis le
début de la saison de son côté l'équipe
des mureaux et dernière du classement
quelques étages plus bas en première
division de district ont joué pour le
compte de la 4e journée carrière
grésillons s'impose sur le terrain
d'aubergenville 2 1 même score pour
sartrouville de face à voisins ou alors
s'ils gagnent par la plus petite des
marges 1 à 0 contre vallée 78 matchs
nuls et spectaculaire entre le chesnay
houllier paul bailly noisy
ces deux rencontres se sont soldées par
un 3 partout enfin bûcher l'oise gagne 3
0 sur le terrain de gargenville la
prochaine journée est programmée le 8
novembre prochain
on va maintenant ouvrir une page rugby
dans le championnat de fédérale 2
plaisir s'est imposé ce week-end contre
le rugby club baulois le score 32 à 20
cette deuxième victoire de la saison
permet aux joueurs de sébastien roncalli
de remonter au classement et de se
retrouver à la huitième place après cinq
journées l'objectif annoncé du milieu de
classement 1 n'est pas loin en fédérale
3 de rugby en jouer ce week-end pour le
compte de la 5e journée très beau
week-end pour versailles après avoir
emporté une victoire en réserve l'équipe
senior s'impose 45 à 21 sur son terrain
face à clamart et versailles et occupe
ainsi la deuxième place du classement on
écoute la réaction de pierre chevalier
le responsable communication du club
tout était réuni pour pouvoir justement
régalé les spectateurs venus masquer à
porsche fontaine avec un festival
offensif de six essais à 3 pour les
bleus et blancs en première et puis
malheureusement une troisième mi-temps
avorté puisqu'il a fallu quitter le
stade juste après le deuxième match nous
pouvions nous nous rassembler à plus de
6 donc une bonne opération pour les
versailles et qui s'installe à la
deuxième place du classement derrière
g/t au dans le championnat de division
honneur dans la poule une l'union rugby
centre 78,7 inclinés ce week-end contre
paris le score 40 à 10 dans l'autre
rencontre cheuvreux s'est imposé 25 à 13
sur le terrain de créteil choisy au
classement chevreuse et co leader dans
ce championnat 13 points en trois
matches et lui verser 60 18 est lui à 6e
c'était l'un des évènements sportifs
marquants de la semaine dernière dans
les yvelines la fédération française de
golf a présenté son tout nouveau stade
d'entraînement de haute performance au
golf national de saint quentin en
yvelines
un lieu qui pourrait à permettre à la
france de jouer les premiers rôles dans
les prochaines années en montage de
xavier jaglin c'est un concept novateur
en europe le golf national de saint
quentin en yvelines a inauguré ce
mercredi 14 octobre stade d'entre elles
de hautes performances à destination des
futures pépites du golf français des
professionnels un outil pour leur
permettre de performer c'est surtout
c'est une zone qui est d'abord une zone
qui a été étudié spécialement pour la
haute performance c'est à dire
rencontrer les conditions que nos
athlètes vont rencontrer lorsqu'il joue
des compétitions sur les plus beaux et
plus difficile parcours du monde et
cette zone a repris les nos athlètes
vont pouvoir se retrouver dans les
conditions de ses plus grands tournois
un nouvel outil de travail qui a
impressionné le golfeur professionnel
jean gabriel de 86 ans aujourd'hui
l'ancien vainqueur de l'open de france
en 1969 à saint nom la bretèche
quand j'ai commencé moi là au pays
basque puisque je suis relax basse il
n'y aurait pas de practice du tout
c'était nous avions chacun aux balles de
practice très bas et on tape et bien sûr
et on allait ramasser recherché on est
en paix maintenant un bon c'est le
progrès le stade de performance et la
première pierre d'un projet beaucoup
plus large à côté du practice de l'oise
les un dortoir pouvant accueillir 24
sportif et si staff sera construit dans
les prochains mois un plateau
performance sera également développée à
destination des jeunes avec une école de
la préparation physique et du travail
technique avec des modélisations du
swing objectif mettre la nouvelle
génération dans les meilleures
conditions
c'est pas parce qu'on a les meilleures
infrastructures que on a forcément des
champions si je vous mets dans la dans
une formule 1 je suis pas certain que
vous soyez capable de rivaliser avec
hamilton donc il nous faut de très
belles formules 1 et on vient d'en
livrer une mais il nous faut maintenant
les pilotes qui vont pouvoir être
capable de conduire cette formule 1 au
total le nouveau stade de performance a
coûté 4,5 millions d'euros avec 60% de
fonds publics
saint quentin en yvelines et la région
font partie des partenaires sur ce
projet rendez vous dans quelques années
pour voir si ce dispositif a permis de
sortir de nouvelles pépites
l'inauguration de ce stade
d'entraînement était également un grand
moment pour christophe muniesa le
directeur général de la fédération
française de golf à uvrer pendant
plusieurs années sur le projet il était
présent mercredi dernier sur le golf
national nous avons profité de ce moment
pour lui parler du stadium mais
également du golf en france
depuis le déconfinement christophe
muniesa on vient de voir le stadium qui
met à être inauguré ici au golf national
j'imagine que c'est une grande
satisfaction de voir ce stadium inauguré
ici oui cet équipement complète les
infrastructures déjà riche du golf
national les différents parcours
également les deux practice
d'entraînement mais il nous manquait au
golf national
ce site spécifique sur lequel on
s'entraîne au petit jeu le petit jeu les
coûts à moins de 100 mètres pour
raisonner simplement
et puis aussi au putting c'est essentiel
dans la performance en golf tous ces
petits coups qui se joue à proximité du
trou sur lesquels il faut être très
performant
si vous voulez gravir les échelons du
golf mondial est-ce que ça fait rentrer
le golf national dans une nouvelle ère
où ou pas ou c'est une continuité
finalement tout cas ça donne au golf
national
une version plus aboutie de l'équipement
je l'évoquais on a commencé ici pas
reconstruire avant toute chose un très
grand parcours reconnu comme tel
d'ailleurs le parcours de l'albatros qui
a entre autres accueilli les open de
france mais aussi la ryder cup
mais au delà du parc où il fallait
compléter ses infrastructures par
d'autres pans qui permettent de
s'entraîner au golf avec à l'esprit
l'ambition d'aller vers le plus haut
niveau globalement le golf dans les
yvelines prend de l'ampleur en ressent
on assez mascara sur sur le visage en ce
moment depuis le confine le
déconfinement le golf a pris de
l'ampleur
oui alors dans les yvelines c'est un
véritable laboratoire puisque c'est le
département le plus golfique de france
vous avez plus de 30 golf dans les
yvelines et la région ile de france et
la région dans laquelle il ya tout
simplement le plus de golfeurs plus de
150 milles de le faire licencier en ile
de france donc
il y avait une belle carte à jouer pour
cette discipline dans ce territoire et
le golf a répondu répondu présent
effectivement dès lors qu'on a pu
retourner sur les parcours dès la
première phase de déconfinement de le 11
mai il ya eu un véritable engouement
pour cette pratique était déjà assez
populaire et qui est en train de le
devenir encore plus
nous on le mesure sur le nombre de
licenciés et sur le nombre de
pratiquants occasionnels et on considère
que le nombre de licenciés dans le
territoire francilien sur l'année va
être au niveau de celui de ce qu'il
était en 2019
donc on va pour ainsi dire pas perdre de
joueurs réguliers et on est en train de
gagner des nouveaux joueurs de l'ordre
de 3 à 4 % sur le territoire francilien
s'est pas forcément équivalent au
systématique sur d'autres régions qui
peuvent être plus impactée par le
tourisme golfique
on pense notamment à la côte d'azur au
littoral atlantique mais en tout état de
cause
oui le golf a le vent en poupe dans
l'île de france et plus particulièrement
dans les yvelines et à proximité de
saint quentin en yvelines
justement ces nouveaux golfeurs ils ont
quel type de profil alors ils sont
plutôt les avait répertorié oui on
essaye de monitorer ont conduit des
études est à l'image de ce qu'on a déjà
observé dans le cadre de la conduite du
de la création des 100 petits
équipements urbains
ça c'était sur la période on va dire
2010-2018 1 à l'aube de l'accueil de la
ryder cup
on a une typologie de nouveaux golfeurs
qui est plutôt plus jeunes 1 la moyenne
d'âge du golfeur en france et 50 ans
pour autant si on regarde les licenciés
de moins de 18 ans on a cinquante mille
licenciés de moins de 18 ans donc
dans cette période qui a immédiatement
suivi le confinement on a eu plus de
jeunes on a un public aussi qui est plus
féminin sur la proportion à l'échelle
nationale on à 30% de joueuses 70 % de
joueurs et là sur les nouveaux golfeurs
on est plutôt à 40 60
donc on cherche évidemment et on espère
pouvoir continuer de surfer sur cette
vague
avec plus de féminines et plus de jeunes
golfeurs christophe millet est ce que le
golf peut devenir tendance alors on a
observé dont on va dire la fin des
années 80 une
notion comparable1 de sport à la mode de
sport tendance et ça nous a permis
d'accroître de manière considérable le
nombre de licenciés au début des années
80 il y avait à peine trente mille
golfeurs en france et aujourd'hui on est
monté à plus de 400 mille licenciés 700
villes pratiquants de nouveau comme on
observe dans les pays anglo saxons est
également en scandinavie il ya une
véritable effervescence autour de la
pratique du golf
actuellement ça tient à la nature de la
pratique on joue en plein air on peut
jouer seul ou à plusieurs
donc c'est un sport qui est beaucoup
moins qu'au vite des pendant que
d'autres types de pratiques est
indéniablement il ya un engouement
autour de la pratique du golf
on espère évidemment l'on ait soutenu
parce que l'avenir du golf et est
radieux autant niveau loisir que haut
niveau alors pour ce qui est de la
pratique loisir très clairement
la pratique est soutenu et on souhaite
que ça continue dans les dents les mois
dans les années qui viennent on est
plutôt optimiste pour ce qui est de la
pratique de haut niveau il ya eu 1
véritable progrès observés au cours des
dernières années des dernières même
décennie avec des joueurs français et
des françaises qui s'illustre sur les
différents circuits très clairement
aujourd'hui le golf français ne peut pas
s'enorgueillir d'un joueur dans le top
ten mondial ce n'est pas encore le cas
il ya beaucoup de signes tout à fait
positif qui plaident en ce sens et on
souhaite que le golf national contribuer
à cet effort du golf français en mettant
à disposition de ses meilleurs talents
des infrastructures qui doivent
permettre l'émergence d'un champion
français au plus haut niveau
merci beaucoup créé sa poigne asa merci
à vous on voit maintenant parler des
jeux olympiques de 2024 une quinzaine de
collectivités yvelinoise auront atteint
centre de préparation pour les hadjis
hall a commis le comité d'organisation
des jeux olympiques vient de confirmer
cette information lui en cours et les
clayes-sous-bois en font notamment à
partie les précisions d'eléonore
sinoquet et nicolas kirillovitch 16
collectivités 19 équipements ont été
retenues pour devenir des centres de
préparation pour les athlètes en 2024
les yvelines auront donc la part belle
pour le grand rendez vous sportif que
sont les jeux olympiques
le gymnase maurice baquet de guyancourt
recevra les entraînements de judo pour
accueillir les sportifs la ville a lancé
la construction de deux salles d'arts
martiaux
les travaux devraient s'achever en juin
coût de l'opération 2 2 à 2 5 millions
d'euros subventionnés je pense que c'est
effectivement liés à ces nouvelles
installations qui vont arriver l'an
prochain et donc qui permettent un
confort d'installation on pense aussi à
la proximité du lieu olympiques puisque
le lyon olympique aura probablement lieu
pour le judo sous la tour eiffel
c'était un besoin un vrai besoin pour la
ville de guyancourt de toute façon du
côté des clayes-sous-bois l'annoncent a
aussi été bien accueillie la commune a
été retenue pour sa piste de bmx situé
dans le parc du carillon est créée en
2010 est en remplacement un terrain de
football à notre site et en être
reconnue donc les équipes devront
choisir parmi les différents sites au
moment des jo
nous espérons que nous aurons choisis
par une équipe de haut niveau et
pourquoi pas espérer l'équipe de france
si une vingtaine de lieux yvelinois est
déjà connu d'autres dossiers sont encore
à l'étude comme l'athlétisme à
guyancourt
une fois n'est pas coutume je vous
propose maintenant de parler de ce qu'il
à l'ancienne skieuse professionnelle
florence masnada fait partie des
légendes de sa discipline notamment
remporté deux médailles de bronze aux
jeux olympiques de 1992 et 1998 nous
l'avons rencontré au golf de
feucherolles c'est notre interview
express
regardez
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
parce que j'étais au pied des montagnes
et je me suis dit que ça serait bien de
monter au sommet des montagnes savoir
les descendre rapidement
les médailles olympiques j'ai eu la
chance d'avoir
deux médailles de bronze olympique et ce
sont des événements qui sont graves et
la dernière la médaille de bronze aux
jeux à nagano en 98
bon c'était le fait qu'au dernier mais
c'est une médaille en descente la
discipline reine je suis concerné par
l'environnement
ce que j'aimerais c'est que le sport
soit encore plus plus solidaires au
niveau de l'environnement et fassent des
efforts aussi montre l'exemple pour pour
les jeunes générations
on passe maintenant notre page agenda
[Musique]
dans cet agenda du football un match
capital pour poissy l'épicier qui
reçoivent ce samedi à 18 heures l'équipe
de sainte geneviève à l'occasion de la
9e journée du championnat de nationale 2
et joueurs coaches et à part laurent
fournier à la recherche de leur première
victoire de la saison doivent l'emporter
pour remonter au classement
ils sont pour l'instant bon dernier du
championnat en football on jouera
également sur les terrains de régionale
3 mort par recevra les ulis ce dimanche
à 15 heures à l'occasion de la 4e
journée du championnat les morlaisiens
promis cette saison ont à coeur de se
relancer après leur première défaite de
la saison contre versailles sur le score
de 4 à 3 la rencontre est programmée au
stade du bout des clous n'hésitez pas à
venir les soutenir
enfin il y aura du rugby ce dimanche
dans le championnat de fédérale 3
l'entente maisons laffitte saint germes
en les poissy se déplacera sur le
terrain à d'evreux ce dimanche 25
octobre le mlsgp pour l'instant leader
de cette poule une espère le rester
son côté est vrai huitième il n'a
disputé que deux matches pour deux
victoires attention au match piège
c'est la fin de cette émission merci
d'avoir suivi très belle soirée sur tv
[Musique]